I'm here with Walter Isaacson what are
we looking at we're looking at the first
draft of the Declaration of Independence
the one done by Thomas Jefferson in
committee with John Adams and Benjamin
Franklin it may have been the last time
Congress appointed a really great
committee but they're doing five
different drafts of the Declaration of
Independence this is the very first one
it's all and so what's significant about
this well first of all you look at the
first paragraph and you discover what it
is they're trying to do it says a decent
respect for the opinions of mankind so
basically this is them trying to do a
propaganda document in a way one that
sort of says here's why we're having
this revolution so they're explaining it
to the world why are we having this
revolution and this does a little bit of
historical background the Revolution had
already started we're already at war
with Great Britain we were at war with
Great Britain but it wasn't totally a
revolution until this document because
this is the first time it says we are
rebelling against the king before this
document came out we were fighting and
we were fighting with the British about
the taxes they imposed and we we the
Americans were blaming it on the
ministers and the people who running the
government in England but we weren't
necessarily rebelling against the king
in this document we say we're going to
be free and independent and separate
from the king of England and so that was
kind of the true declaration of war
before it was hey were ministers the
government it's okay to disagree with
but when you start questioning the king
yeah that's something new which was
questioning the king and that meant we
were going to be totally separate as
opposed to just fighting the current
ministers of England interesting and so
what are these I mean I'm fascinated by
what they decided to actually edit out
and replace it with what is going on up
here I think the most amazing thing is
this great second paragraph well you see
Jefferson right we hold these truths to
be sacred and undeniable
that's what's Crashdown that's what
scratches sacred and undeniable I de
truths come from God that they come from
religion
and what you see is this crossing out
that most of us think Benjamin Franklin
did because those are sort of his
slashes because he was apprentice and he
used the heavy black pen and he used the
backslash the way printers do and he
writes in the words self-evident instead
of sacred and essentially so we don't
know for sure that it was Franklin no
but most of the scholars think it's Ben
Franklin's backslashes I do because I've
spent a lot of time looking at Ben
Franklin's original papers which were in
the Yale University Library and so I'm
used to his penmanship I'm used to the
way he uses you know back slashes and to
me that's pretty distinctively Ben
Franklin Carl Becker and other great
historians also believed that was Ben
Franklin's at it I see and it's also the
nature of the Edit what he decided to
cross out and replace it with is also in
the spirit of Benjamin Franklin
absolutely he uses the word self-evident
self-evident means that we're believing
in rationality and reason as a way to
figure out what truths we hold and that
was very Ben Franklin like he was a
student of David Hume who was the
Scottish enlightenment thinker who
always used the phrase self-evident and
even of Isaac Newton because Ben
Franklin was a great scientist and he
believed that there were certain truths
that just come from nature and OB are
self-evident you can just look at nature
and understand them so those are phrases
he would have used they don't really
come from John Locke which is the source
of inspiration of what Jefferson was
writing they come from sort of the
Scottish enlightenment and David Hume
and from Sir Isaac Newton so it feels
like Ben Franklin I say one of the
things about history is sort of trying
to figure out you know who's making it
and how looking at documents and just
getting a feel for oh they were sitting
in a small room on Market Street in
Philadelphia in 1776 trying to edit this
thing Wow this is fascinating stuff
another interesting thing is they play
with the UM phrase they're endowed with
certain in
animal rights and then you see John
Adams is I think influenced endowed by
their creator is in this draft it's
written in and you can see the John
Adams influence what he's also balancing
the role of divine providence our
Creator with self-evident truths so it's
not like they're saying it all comes
from religion or none comes from
religion it's a great balance between
what truths are self-evident but there
are things that come from all of us
being equal in the eyes of our Creator
so this is where they wrote it they are
endowed by their creator with and then
it says well it says it ends up saying
with certain inalienable rights with
this draft it's a little bit yeah it's a
little bit hard to read but inalienable
rights means rights that you can't take
away from people it's interesting too
that they say they they don't refer to
God and they certainly never refer to
Jesus Christ in the document they
referred to their Creator and I think
they're trying to be very inclusive
because Ben Franklin and Thomas
Jefferson were deists they believed that
there was an ultimate creator of the
universe but they were not very specific
about religion of a particular type of
dogma or religious beliefs they didn't
say by God nor do they say kind of their
Creator with a capital C where I'd it's
actually interesting the capitalization
in this document goes back and forth
okay so often did in the 18th century
Jefferson never capitalizes creator but
I think when John Adams writes it you
can sometimes see it's capitalized and I
think in the final document it's usually
capitalized
I see so it is kind of well you can see
that they don't have a specific way of
doing it but this is why it's so
wonderful you were reminded these are
real flesh-and-blood people sitting in a
room trying to balance the role of
divine providence and the role of
rationality and reason and giving us our
rights and they're fiddling with the
words and doing it by committee oh yeah
actually I was looking for the
inalienable rights that's right here the
inalienable right and an alien rights
and you can see this and it's literally
like you know you're editing a paper of
mine right and they're taking out the
phrase inherent because it doesn't
really add much to it the important
thing is you cannot give up those rights
nor can the king take those rights away
that's what they're trying to emphasize
fascinating